it sounds like there's great work being
done through this framework I just
wanted to connect the conversation to
someone that we had last week who's
Harry Belafonte very famous civil rights
activists in the u.s. one of the things
that he mentioned was that traditionally
he kind of conceptualized philanthropy
as the rich giving back to the poor as a
means to kind of offset some of the
social injustice a--'s that they have
caused prior to that working in private
enterprise and you know especially
launching this investment arm with AIG
is that a criticism that that you face
often and how do you how do you respond
to that can you define what do you mean
by the criticism of what I'm not sure
the criticism of private enterprise
capitalism in particular kind of leading
philanthropic initiatives to combat
social injustice which some people argue
is in part manufactured by a class
system created by capitalism itself well
I would yeah i would also answer may be
in several point you know first i think
yes there is a lot of uncomfort among
the philanthropists with the notion of
you know receiving a return on the
provision of social goods so that's one
point second point the vehicle that i
created with energy was commercial you
know it was focused on double bottom
line you know impact investing but we
were hoping through private equity to
achieve you know good financial returns
and we did have criticism saying that it
was impact washing that the financial
institution just wanted to use it for
the PR but i think that at that point
you know you know it wasn't true it was
just a bunch of people who worked hard
because they believed in it and it was
in a way very gay stick from my side
because i felt
very inspired with this idea so for me
it was fantastic to work on it and push
for it irrespective of what the
organization was doing in the wrong in
other parts and the fact that this
commercial organization which many said
is not really prone to support it has
provided 150 million dollars out of
their balance sheet to support this
initiative and was ready to increase it
three times to do it i think is great so
if we can move large commercial
institutions to play in this field still
getting the financial returns because
without it you cannot do it then I think
the impact would be tremendous important
is that it becomes their core business
that is not the corporate social
responsibility on the side driven out of
the marketing department but they find
ways to create new products for bottom
of the pyramid to drive their
profitability and business lines and
then it becomes impactful I think
they're to complement what what what
judy has just said I think the reality
is that there is a spectrum of
motivations some of which we all might
be more comfortable with and some some
some of which less so from the purely
cynical window-dressing greenwashing
marketing all the way through to very
enlightened understanding of the fact
that there is an enormous market out
there that by and large is larger in
number than our traditional Western
consumptive markets and therefore it's
simply a commercial opportunity bringing
it back to the sort of personal speaking
for myself I noticed attention at aureus
capital for example where I felt that I
was perhaps in a more of a believer in
that side of the mission than my
colleagues on the ground that were you
know cutting the deals as it were but
then I made peace with it in the
following way which was if at the end of
the day between us we are getting the
dollars to move into these SMEs and to
grow these SMEs the fact that I might be
more focused on generating as great
social environmental and governance
impacts as possible and they might be
more focused on on
and the financial engineering of the
transaction perhaps the ultimate return
wasn't the some greater than its parts
and didn't we get to a positive result
that's promoting equity through social
and public goods for all as opposed to
in a sense sitting in judgment that
other motivations weren't perhaps as
pure is openly mine